mark stein is in the bubble he's been
covering the nba since 1994 the new york
times reporter
mark joins us now where are you right
now mark
i am i found a little bit of quiet the
nine o'clock hour here is always busy
because that's testing hour for the
media but i
i found some quiet not far from the
testing
rooms they got they got like four hotel
rooms set aside where we
go in and test and
we're glamorous it's glamorous
we're three days away how do you feel
i think you oh look the basketball is
fantastic i mean to be in a gym
you know i'm not gonna lie to you this
squeak of sneakers
it is glorious it's great to be there
uh you know we all have lamented what we
don't have here but one of the perks we
do have is
arena seats more accustomed to the way
we used to back in the day when
when old guys like you and i were
getting started you know we're much
closer to the court in one of the three
gyms we are on the floor
so the seats are amazing you hear a lot
you hear a lot more than you would
at a normal game and just i think
the teams the players
guys are really happy to be playing
again and i and and i've heard this
comment from multiple coaches that
even practices i think guys just are so
happy to be back in the gym that
even the kind of grumbling you would get
after five practice days in a row you
you're not hearing that guys want to be
in the gym they want to play
the lou williams situation here i i
maintain if he had been a laker this
would be
leading the national news but here he is
with the clippers he goes to atlanta
goes to a strip club to order takeout
but
so what is the violation for lou
williams okay so the violation is he he
had an excused absence unlike
you know the rashaan holm story where
rashaan holmes of the sacramento kings
takes a few steps over a campus border
to to pick up
delivery he's not allowed to pick up you
know this is
lou williams was was on an excused
absence but
he goes to a public place and obviously
we're all going to make jokes about
where he went and where he ended up but
any public place is to me an egregious
violation i mean
the bubble has started you are in you're
on an excused absence
to attend a family funeral does it
really need to be explained that the
only place you should go
is that family funeral and get back on
get back on a plane and get back to this
bubble
as quickly as possible i mean it i i
really don't think that needed to be
spelled out i mean it is
it was irresponsible it was selfish
and you know thank god it was
photographed because
you know he could have gotten back here
and no one would have known where he was
and and that would have been 10 times
worse but the reality is
the nba has limitations in in how it can
sanction him
and so rishon holmes and lou williams
get the same
10-day back in quarantine basically
because that's what the league has
collectively bargained with the union on
these matters
you know everybody's saying why why are
the punishments the same well that's why
the nba
really didn't have much of an option
assess the clippers situation
uh from a basketball perspective that we
came into
the bubble and they were as deep as any
team in the nba
and a lot of people like them to emerge
from the western conference here but
how would you handicap them i mean joe
kim noah
is their center i mean well here's the
thing they do have time
i mean seedings matter
nothing in terms of home court advantage
they matter
as far as who you might play so
obviously they don't want to fall too
far down the ladder because you don't
want to make your road
unnecessarily tougher having to play
tougher teams but
they do have time that you know all
these teams are playing eight games
before we even get to the playoffs so
yeah i mean
it doesn't look great right now when you
have no harold
no lou williams pat beverly just got
back no zubach i mean they're missing
they're no landry shaman i mean they are
missing
a slew of rotation players but they do
have time on their side and
uh you know i i'm sure
there's no question i mean doc rivers is
i would say uneasy about it but
it's way too soon for them to panic i
mean the damage
we'll be able to assess the damage
better when
the standings are finished and we see
how how far
they fall down the list and you know
kind of what that does to them in terms
of
first round opponent but you know they
still have that kawhi leonard guy and
they still have paul george so
you know they'll i think they're going
to be okay how do you think history is
going to view kawhi leonard let's say he
wins a couple more titles here
and we of course start with our all-time
list when we start with how many titles
have you won
kawhi's sort of that enigma that um
you know not quite sure how to
categorize him
as he's a great postseason player but
we've seen that he sort of is a
really good uh regular season player
it is a fascinating case because he just
also doesn't do
anything to sell himself he doesn't
give us an ounce to work with especially
during the regular season when
you know it's all about load management
but
he's probably not going to get his just
due unfortunately when you
you know we always talk about super team
the san antonio spurs
in 2013 and 2014 that was a super team
and he made them the super team when you
add kawhi leonard
to duncan parker and ginobili and we
never look at the spurs that way
but they easily could have won and some
which they should have won in 2013
they absolutely disassembled
the heatless in 2014 and broke that team
up
that was the super team and kawhi
leonard is what put it at that level
and we really don't even discuss it and
and
you know if he we if the clippers win it
all
now look if the clippers win it all see
my contention is no matter who
if any of the top three teams win if the
lakers win
people are gonna say lebron this doesn't
count this isn't real if the clippers
win
win a real championship this is the only
way you could win with one of these
the bucks oh giannis you got to leave
milwaukee this doesn't count so
we're gonna hear that no matter who wins
but if the clippers win it all
and kawhi leonard is the first guy to
win titles with three teams if he beats
lebron in that race
i mean historically that's huge i agree
i just don't know if history is going to
treat him
maybe fairly but you're right he doesn't
go out of his way but i
look it's just not who he is and i'm tim
duncan never
tried to curry favor he never tried to
you know be friendly with anybody
he just went out and won championships
we're talking to mark stein the new york
times uh
nba writer um the tom thibodeau
moved by the knicks i i as much as i
respect him
i do like him it just seems so
uninspiring you got the same ownership
here
how does this change the knicks in your
opinion
well from the minute leon rose took over
everyone in this league especially in
coaching circles thought
tom thibodeau was getting this job and
he did you know they interviewed
10 11 guys and you know that's what
teams do now there is a value in that
because you're getting
you know you're getting you're getting a
look at possible assistance you're
getting information from other
organizations to put in your database
but no matter who they talk to everybody
everybody thought tibbs was getting this
job and look tibs is a fantastic coach
the the issue here is leon rose has come
in and basically every move made has
been someone
from his inner circle who's been there
for the last 10 years and that's why
that's why uninspiring is the is the
word you chose i mean we we could have
probably predicted
all of these moves from the minute leon
rose took over and he's
and this is the problem leon rose was a
decorated player agent
he's never run a team he's never run an
organization
and if you bring in you know a coach you
used to represent
and world wide west who was part of the
same representation firm
and you know if your whole scouting
operation is just you know people who
have been part of your your group your
clique for a long time
i mean it is i no question
it's worrisome but ultimately
this is a talent thing and the knicks
are so
far adrift of where they should be
talent-wise
they've got up they've gotta shore up
the roster for one but also they gotta
they've gotta
leon rose has to build a good basketball
operation
but who's gonna wanna play there mark
that's the key these free agents
aren't our age they don't go boy i'd
love to play for the knicks in the
garden
like that's totally right they're going
to have they're going to have to draft
and trade well
first and and and change the perception
of that organization but look it's look
i still think the nick the knicks are
still a marquee team and
madison square garden is even this
generation guys still want to play in
that building that does
carry a little bit of weight but yeah
with free agents when you hear
kevin durant say how uncool they are i
mean that resonates
and that's what i'm saying leon rose is
gonna have to be the one who leads the
way
to change that reputation and because he
has no experience in this
arena that i mean that's where the
skepticism comes from
stay safe down there and uh we look
forward to reading your uh
your columns here in the new york times
mark great to talk to you again thank
you
sounds good guys that's uh mark stein
new york times reporter
been covering the nba since 1994.